preferred to have a father figure I'm  okay with myself right now no but you  didn't answer would you have preferred  it I can't have a preference because I  don't know why it used to happen okay  yes or no would you have preferred it no  because I like my life right now okay  okay it's crazy  I just want to quickly say yeah a lot of  people understand the idea of raising a  child you know you need to have like a  trap you need to have loads of people  around you that has no correlation with  having not having a father figure I feel  like there's a difference between  support and having a tribe to raise your  child because it takes more than one  person you need the aunties you need the  friends you need the cousins the  siblings whatever it may be but a father  figure a father period is something that  is irreplaceable when it comes to a  child especially when they're young